[Music]
welcome to our talk building IOT
applications on Google cloud I said the
wrong one
I am Gabe Weiss I'm a developer advocate
for Google on Google cloud platform
specializing in IOT also on stage with
me we have Calum Barnes he's a product
manager on IOT core we have Martine of
Varela sorry I'm like losing people's
names already developer advocate on
startups we have Alicia William uh sorry
Rob Wormald next to her he is a
developer programs engineer on angular
and lastly Alicia Williams she is a
developer advocate on G suite and Google
cloud platform so given the range of
people that might give you an idea of
what we're talking about today so now
you know who we are I want to know how
who you all are so how many developers
operators infrastructure people that are
doing the work with show hands how many
do I have on that woohoo nice welcome
thank you who out there our executive
sea-levels business decision-makers and
some of the same hands are going up so
startups yeah all right cool how many
data scientists do we have any data
scientists good oh yeah nice everyone
else do your arms work so now that we
all know who each other's our
application development there are a lot
of decisions that need to be made before
you can start laying down code for an
application I don't want to fool you
into thinking that yes we're gonna be
building an end-to-end app today in the
45 minutes we've got but I don't want to
fool you into thinking that you can
actually do it on stage all these
decisions that need to be made we made a
lot of them beforehand what I do want
you to walk away from this talk with are
three things one understanding what what
questions you want to be asking yourself
about the app that you're gonna be
building what are the different parts
that are out there what do we have
product why is in Google cloud platform
that help you build these IOT
applications to that it really is from a
raw code standpoint easy to build these
end-to-end apps there's a lot of moving
parts there's a lot of products involved
but the actual implementation of each
part is actually really easy to do and
we'll be showing you some of that and
thirdly that what you can put together
in this short amount of time is
immediately useful the data that you can
get from these simple applications can
immediately be introspected can be
looked at can be used to get ROI on
whatever business that you're that
you're doing what I don't want you to
take away from this talk is that
whatever you put together in that short
amount of time is production ready
it's not product managers don't let your
ends teams tell you that what they put
together in a day for an IOT app is
totally ready for release and ends teams
don't let your product managers tell you
that hey I saw it Google they put
together an app in an hour that's enough
time right it's not don't let them tell
you that it is so what's the first thing
that you need in order to build an
application does anyone have any ideas
you can shout it out if you're shy it's
okay I'll still give you my answer but
does I don't have an idea what do you
need before you can build an application
an idea absolutely first shot nice so
you need an idea you need to know what
you're building towards in order to
build an application I'm gonna walk you
through what our idea is and how it
dictated some of the technology choices
that we made in order to build our
application the question that I wanted
answered who up here amongst us is the
coolest on stage who's the most nervous
who's anxious being on stage in front of
everyone so there's one really reliable
way to detect stress in humans it's a
chemical called cortisol you can test
for it in your blood and its presence in
the amount of it tells you empirically
how stressed out you are I asked the
organizers and they did tell me I'm not
allowed to create a biohazard situation
on stage so I couldn't do blood testing
so the next step what about blood
pressure so blood pressure how elevated
is will tell you how stressed you are
let's think about a blood pressure cuff
it requires that you can detect your
heart rate and you have to be able to
apply and release pressure in an even
way around your arm it's totally doable
with IOT but maybe a little ambitious
for a 50-minute session so I kind of got
rid of that so our last option that I
fell back to is this thing called the
vagal tone impulse this is your vagus
nerve the vagus nerve is what regulates
your heart rate it's what keeps your
heart rate within normal amounts during
times of extreme stress the vagal tone
impulse is suppressed so that your heart
rate can skyrocket so that you can be
ready to do whatever you want the the
common you've probably heard about it is
the fight-or-flight response so once
you're in that mode your heart rate can
go up even though physical you're you
don't have any physical need for it so
for example if your nerve
and you want to tear it off stage and
run away you'll get your but your body
foot your your body flooded with blood
so that you can do that faster so why am
I giving this biology lesson I could
have just said hey we want to know who's
nervous on stage and away we go
the reality is I'm vamping a little bit
I wanted to give my team a little bit of
a head start so that we could actually
show you as we're building what we're
doing so I needed to give them a little
bit of time also there's still a monster
lying outside so I wanted to make sure
that everyone could come in before I'm
talking about the technical stuff so
architecture here's the architecture in
its entirety for the application we are
building today we're going to be
creating a simple data-driven
application using the IOT devices that
Callum is building for us as we speak
for each piece of this architecture I'm
going to talk through the product that
we chose the other options that are
available to you in Google cloud
platform for that piece of the
architecture and then show you a little
bit of the implementation that we're
working on as we speak
so first let's chat about this device
that we're making it will be able to
measure your heart rate and temperature
and between those two data points we're
gonna be able to tell who's really
nervous up on stage heart rate in
particular is going to be our primary
indicator so hardware and IOT how do you
pick what hardware you want to use once
you picked your hardware how do you pick
what's what programming language what
software you want to use on that device
there's a problem for those of us that
are building out these devices right now
and the reality is is who was alive in
the 70s it was first question okay good
there's at least some of us I don't feel
too old yet so in the 70s we add VHS VHS
and Betamax today I'm gonna own a
Betamax player yeah yeah me too
next if you heard about laser discs and
I don't hear about laser discs yeah all
right so laser discs and DVDs and now
we've got blu-ray and HD hopefully most
of the room wouldn't know about those so
it's the idea of standards each of those
technologies eventually resolved into a
standard that most of the market could
adopt an IOT we don't have standards
right now it is a complete Wild West you
could pick any hardware and any software
and it would still work this is just a
small sampling of the options that
you've got up there today sometimes an
environmental factor will help you
narrow down this choice so if you're
working on the side of a mountain your
options will slim down you've got
communication problems you've got power
consumption issues
that can help dictate what hard your
hardware that you're picking the reality
is is that for most large-scale IOT
installations you're gonna have custom
hardware that gets built you're gonna
have a microcontroller with custom
sensors that really defines the minimum
device that you need to accomplish
whatever the goal is our only real
requirement is to read analog sensors or
heartbeat a hurry and temperature
sensors are analog they're off-the-shelf
so we needed something that could speak
analog we also want it super easy to set
up
we've only got 45 minutes to build the
entire thing so I wanted to be sure that
whatever we picked would be really easy
to set up the Python libraries have
everything we need everything that we
need to do this end-to-end Python has
libraries for them and it was out of the
box we wanted something that could run
Python so our device is an Arduino so
that we could read the analog devices
really easily connected over serial to a
Raspberry Pi which is super easy to
connect and runs Python production
obviously for most IOT that's not what
you're going to end up using it's not
cost-effective but for our purposes just
to highlight the technology it's going
to work great so let's take a look if we
could at the device the columns building
could we switch to demo one please what
we're seeing here is we can see the
arduino chip right here on top of our
device and inside this case is the
Raspberry Pi the two sensors that we're
seeing now is the heart rate sensor
which is on a little ear clip and then
we've got the temperature sensor this
little probe guy so I'm gonna have that
temperature sensor in my mouth and we'll
see how accurate a reading we can get as
I'm trying to give a talk with a sensor
in my mouth so before we check out the
software that columns got on my device
running it can we switch back to slides
now please I want to talk to us a little
bit about ingesting our data yay so
before we can ingest data there's
something I want to talk about and it's
gonna be the hill that I died upon for
IOT and it's a question what does the s
in IOT stand for security it's funny
because there's no s and IOT you get
that so there's a couple of anecdotes I
want to tell about security that kind of
highlights why you should care a couple
years ago a bunch of you may remember
that the whole internet large swathes of
it went down for hours it was something
called the mirai botnet attack and what
Mirai software did is it scanned the
whole
internet for unsecured IOT devices it
found eleven point three million of them
it launched a massive botnet attack
against Dyn the domain services for the
whole internet and it took the internet
down for a bunch of hours so that's the
macro view all of those devices could
take down something like the internet
for a while
micro view last year there was a single
temperature sensor in a fish tank in a
casino and it was connected to an
internal machine so it could regulate
the temperature of that of that fish
tank and an enterprising young Finnish
hacker found that temperature sensor
hacked it got access to the neutral
machine and pulled out 10 gigabytes of
High Roller data from that casino they
lost millions of dollars and lost face
to all those high rollers so this is why
you need to care about security the
macro view with the more I bought in an
attack in the micro with this Finnish
hacker taking all of the casino data I
could talk for a long time about how you
can countermeasure this how you can
secure your devices I'm not going to
because on Thursday at 10:20 there is
security and IOT talk it's being done by
a colleague and a partner of ours that
is a really good talk so if you want to
learn and go into depth on security and
IOT go to their talk because it's gonna
be really good for ingestion then back
to that this is why I pick cloud IOT
core as our choice for that cloud IOT
core is the Google cloud platform
gateway for devices to send their Kalama
tree data up into the cloud it handle
things like device authorization that
that security piece I'm talking about
management it allows you to configure
your devices from the cloud you can send
messages back down to your devices it
allows you to have your devices report
their state so you can check the health
of your fleet from the cloud without
having to talk directly to your device
it's a managed service it's just an
endpoint that you talk to you so you
configure your devices to talk to a URL
there's no client libraries so if space
is an issue if we're on a
microcontroller that only 200k of space
so two premium you don't want to have
client libraries I have two Cora lets
you handle that alright so before I
still talk till I show you the the code
that Callum is running on the device I
want to talk to you about what the other
options that you could do instead of
talking to I of G core what are some
other possibilities you could do you
could leave IOT core and talk directly
to the message the event queue system
that backs it cloud pub/sub so you could
cut out our two core I left the
management block on here on purpose
because if you skip IOT core while
you're left with is having to manage
your devices you have to authorize them
you have to deal with them if one of
them goes it gets compromising you have
to shut it off you have to now manage
all of that yourself in software another
option you could skip all of that and
talk directly to your data store now I'm
not on top of having to manage all your
devices you also have this problem where
what if your right to your data store
fails someone kicks a cable or sunspots
or just plain networking problem now all
of that retry code to get your data into
your data warehouse instead of already
having your data in the cloud in
something safe like pub/sub now you have
to redo it from your device which for
devices network is your battery killer
if you have to keep running network from
your device that's gonna run you're out
of batteries and causes this cascade of
failure so if you skip all of this and
talking directly to datastore your
devices or an edge machine is now
responsible for doing all of that retry
logic so again this is why we wanted
with IOT core it's the way to go so
we're still almost ready to talk to that
code no I lied we actually already
talked to the code from calm now so if
now we could switch to the demo one
awesome and Callum is actually gonna
take us through the code that he wrote
on the device thanks Gabe so what I've
done since we only have 45 minutes here
is basically copied most of the code
from the IOT core Python tutorial
written by another great dev advocate
Gus class and what that does for us is
make two things really easy connecting
and authenticating with IOT core and
then sending messages to IOT core over
mqtt and those are the messages that are
going to contain the data we're going to
build our application with so you can
see in this Python sample that comes
straight from the website we have a
create job function if you go to that
security talk Gabe mentioned on Thursday
you'll find out even more about how IOT
authentication works but we create a
special jot authentication token based
on a private key on the device and this
function makes it really really easy to
generate that and send at IOT core and
then the rest of what we have is
basically boilerplate PAHO MQTT code to
connect to the IOT core MQTT front ends
all i've added in here in the last few
minutes is some configuration
information about the specific project
that martin set up when we got started
and then a little bit of code to talk to
the serial input from the Arduino and
toggle the LED when we get over some
limits that we'll talk about later so
all of this has been pretty easy to
write because I was able to leverage the
samples that we have on the IOT core
documentation website thanks Gabe
so we've now covered kind of the why and
how of devices and ingestion in the
cloud getting up there next up we need
to get all of that data from cloud
pub/sub where IOT core puts it into our
data storage we've decided to use Google
cloud functions to do that cloud
functions are our service methods they
can be called with either an HTTP GET or
post call or triggered from something
that happens in Google cloud platform
for us we're we've using we're using
pub/sub as our trigger so any message
that comes into cloud pub/sub will fire
off this function since I know Martin's
probably already on board since he
finished this like in the first two
minutes and we're gonna cut over to
Martin and we're gonna show some of the
code that he did so we need to switch to
demo two please yep
ask you Gabe so we just finished five
minutes ago I didn't have that much time
deploying this function that I called
telemetry to fire store again as Gabe
said what this is doing this function is
subscribed to a parts of topic so that
every time one of the devices that we
are building since telemetry to IOT core
that sends a possible message and
triggers a new execution or a new
instance of this function
let's get take a look at the code here
as you can see this is written in
JavaScript and it's running on a node.js
version 6 environment at the top I'm
just calling and importing the library
that I'm using to write to firebase
sorry to fire store and initialize in
the app because we're running on this
managed environment we don't need to do
any authentication that's 100 for us and
then the about 20 lines that are next is
the actual function the function expects
an event from pub/sub
I will check if it has data otherwise
I'm gonna throw an error then I'm gonna
base64 decode the payload parse it into
a JavaScript object so it's easier to
grab the attributes and then this is
where I run right to the DB how firebase
works or how firestore works is that it
stores a collection of documents and
each document can have a bunch of
different attributes in this case we're
sending the timestamp temperature and
bpm as you can see here and this is the
path to the where I want to write the
documents and then it's just whether it
fails for note I'm gonna console.log it
just for reference and that's pretty
much it sweet thanks martine so this is
the glue that joins our event messaging
system as the temperatures coming in to
our warehouse can we switch back to
slides again please so let's try a bit
about what the other options if you
didn't want to use cloud functions and
there's a reason you might not want to
use cloud functions for IOT there's
really three really good options in in
Google cloud platform for this cloud
functions cloud dataflow and cloud data
proc cloud functions I've already
covered their server lists it's a low
barrier to entry because it's JavaScript
so it's easy to stand up and get going
and it fires once per message coming in
that once per message coming in that's
the catch that's the reason you might
not want to be using cloud functions if
you're managing a fleet of a million
devices and those million devices are
sending a message once a second that's
now a million million firings per second
of this cloud function part of their
cost is number of invocations so if
you've got a system that has a very high
throughput that's why you might want to
look at cloud dataflow on day to proc so
cloud dataflow and data proc are both
managed service they're very similar and
what they can do dataflow is our managed
service for transforming incoming
Batchelor streaming data it can do
pipeline development with the Apache
beam sdk and it handles very high
throughput that's what it's designed to
do data proc is very similar to that it
also handles it very high throughput it
does a lot of the same transforms it's
hosted Apache Hadoop and Apache spark so
really how why would you pick one versus
the other is the platform that you're
familiar with so how do you know when
you should use one versus the other
the answer is it really depends if
you're not doing anything but shuttling
data from point A to point B you're just
taking it from the event system and
pushing it into your data store it
really doesn't matter that much they're
both going to perform really well for
you the invitations per second is what I
was what I've talking about so if you've
got very high throughput that's where
you would want to switch over to data
flow or data proc for me the general
rule of thumb always prototype of cloud
functions get your entire end and
working find out what you don't know get
everything functional and then when the
cost starts to become an issue cut over
to data flow or data proc all right so
we've got ingest we've got devices we've
got pipeline next up we're on to storage
everyone still doing ok out there yeah
so there I I know I'm throwing a lot of
stuff at you very quickly I wish I could
tell you it's gonna get better it's not
I'm gonna continue to throw a lot of
stuff at you very quickly because next
step is storage and there's a lot to
cover so for our application we picked
cloud firestore it's a no sequel
database it's very low latency and Pyrus
and low response time it's perfect for
doing the real-time visualization that I
talked about at the beginning because
built into it a native mode it's got a
push mechanism an update mechanism where
anytime you get a data change it fires
call back it's one of the unique pieces
of firestore in our kind of storage
options which is why we decided to pick
it today it's also really easy to stand
up so what are some options if you
didn't want to use cloud fire store we
have a flowchart for that no need to
memorize this it's actually on our
websites at cloud.google.com slash
storage - options memorized that one so
this flow chart is not intended to give
you the be-all-end-all option for your
storage there's a lot of edge cases that
are little gotchas in here but this flow
chart will help you things like is your
data structured or not are you doing
analytics or real-time analysis do you
need mobile SDKs that's what this flow
chart will help you with cost is the
last piece the flow chart won't help you
with cost but it's so dependent on your
individual applications we have tools
online that you can put in things like
general throughput amount of storage you
need the online tools will help guide
you through what your rough monthly cost
will be depending on the storage that
you pick so there's too many on that
flow chart for us to go through all of
them in detail but I want to highlight
just a few and to speak to IOT there's
usually two different things with
storage that your
wanting to care about for an IFC
application there's a real-time analysis
if you're doing things like fault
detection or automatic inference you
want to get a real low latency response
or you're doing really heavy analytics
so iot often is just a vehicle to get
data into the cloud to run analysis on
those are the two things and so I put
them on on this graph so that I can put
our different products on it to give you
just a ballpark finger in the wind what
the different products are good at so
first up fire store I've already pretty
much covered it it's very very good at
real-time and it's not the worse in
analytics but it is a no sequel database
if you're not familiar with sequel
versus no sequel know some people is not
the best at doing really complicated
queries because you have to scan a whole
bunch of rows and then parse for what
you want within it since it's
unstructured data sequel is much better
for running that kind of query where you
can really get at exactly what you want
in the query so that's why I fire
starters where it is next we have cloud
BigTable BigTable is the speediest of
our speedy no sequel databases it's
incredibly fast and it scales up to
really massive amounts of data petabytes
of data are not a problem for BigTable
the reason it's so far on the analytics
left-hand side because it's terrible at
it the way that it is so fast is that it
is incredibly bare-bones
anything that you want on top of it you
have to build there's no tooling built
into it so it's a kind of a blank canvas
no sequel database we would never done
it for today because there's way too
much tooling you'd have to build that
next up is cloud datastore it's much
more of kind of an out of the box no
sequel solution it's got a bunch of
tooling on top of it it's got a very
well developed querying API and it's
easy to understand and use in function
it's very similar to cloud firestore the
tipping point for us with fire stores
why it's so a little bit better in the
real time is that update mechanism that
push mechanism we didn't want to have to
build something to do push to our real a
real time front-end so that's why we
picked it over datastore next we have
cloud sequel our sequel option it's
hosted my suit or Postgres if you need a
sequel database this is the option for
it it's very low latency it's better on
the analytics scale because it's sequel
so it can do more complex queries there
is a gotcha and sequel you should know
about it which is sequel cannot
horizontally scale it can only
vertically scale so if all of your data
fits happily on a single machine awesome
use cloud sequel if all of your data
will enough for today
I could
use cloud sequel there's no way our
sensors today are gonna overwhelm a
single box but I didn't want to
highlight a solution that for most i OT
applications aren't gonna be doable most
IOT is gonna produce enough data that it
would overwhelm sequel right away and
lastly way down in the corner we have
bigquery does anyone know about bigquery
already yeah a bunch of you do if you
don't get familiar if you're doing any
kind of data analytics bigquery is what
you want to use hands down no question
you should be using it and if you're not
doing analytics as part of your IOT
application I would ask you why are you
not doing analytics as part of your IOT
application because it's data and a lot
of it and you can get really cool stuff
out of it so bigquery is it's unique in
the offering and that you use sequel
queries against a no sequel back-end and
it's amazing which means for analytics
it is the best of both worlds you can
use sequel statements and horizontally
scales
it also will scale up to petabytes of
data and you can run queries performant
for the size against that data now
having said that it is performant but
it's not real-time I would never ever
build a real-time application on top of
bigquery because it will be terrible at
it if I had more time or in the session
today and in a perfect world you would
want something like this where that
cloud function is pulling your data out
of pub/sub and putting it into your
real-time analysis datastore like fire
store you would also duplicate the data
over into your data warehouse like
bigquery that way you really get the
best of both worlds for the cost of some
storage which is cheap you get the
real-time analysis you get all of the
the low latency of fire store and you
get the power in the analytics of
bigquery behind it so I've talked a
little bit about latency real-time
processing something that I haven't
talked about yet which I probably I
can't is computing on the edge that's
kind of all the buzzword right now right
you want to compute on the edge be on
the edge I could spend an entire talk
discussing cloud versus the edge versus
hybrid versus fog although fog really is
just edge it's just another buzzword
it's that whole talk is gonna take up
all the time
broadly speaking kind of a finger in the
wind storage doing the cloud if you need
real-time compute low latency do it on
the edge you want to do data
visualization probably safe doing in the
cloud safety checks on a nuclear power
plant please do it on the edge don't do
that MacLeod so we've covered all of our
headless stuff now we've gone from
device up into IOT core IOT core bridged
into cloud pub/sub cloud functions
pulling off a pub/sub dumping it into
fire store all of the no visual stuff so
we still have not answered my question
of who's nervous so let's see if we can
answer those questions I could spend a
really long time talking about all the
front-end possibilities for an IOT
application this is like the tiniest of
samples up there I do not have a
mountain of time to talk about front
ends of all of what your options are so
I'm going to talk about the two options
that that we have picked so we could
have just in one front end but I wanted
to see how many people we could pack up
on stage here I asked if we could do
four they told me I didn't have enough
pedestals to do four so we settled on
two was kind of a negotiation back and
forth so my goals for showing you front
ends to an IT application are twofold I
wanted to show you
real-time visualization and timeslice
visualization of data and I wanted to
show off the front ends ability to
modify metadata around a device and I
talked about earlier IOT core has the
ability to send messages back down to
device and configure them and we're
gonna try that hopefully the demo gods
are kind so first to highlight the
real-time display piece I wanted to talk
about angular that's what we picked how
many of you know what angular is yeah
alright so angular is our batteries
included framework for JavaScript it has
components to do everything that you
would need to do in a web app routing
animation rendering forms aisle 8 and
support integrated testing all of those
things you would want to have in a web
app we've got in angular so at this
point I think we're gonna try and get me
loaded up with a device I think I'm
ready
Rob are you ready to show off your piece
alright so normally you wouldn't ever do
this in production we would have unit
tests we would have integrated tests we
wouldn't be using a device that we just
built on stage here we just played the
demo gods and see how it goes all right
so I'm gonna hold this in this hand and
we're gonna sliding it alright can we
switch to what he won't let demo to and
input 3
okay so let's see I'm shaking like a
leaf but I think I have decent
connection alright so what we're seeing
on screen now is the iteration of the
devices so all right so we've clicked in
Gabe's device hey way to go Gabe where's
my device there we go hey Alicia could
we change my name to something snazzier
Gabe's device is kind of boring I am now
the destroyer of worlds
Thank You Lissa so umm okay
so if we click into that and we're
seeing now these latest readings we
might have some garbage here because
when the heartbeat sensor isn't attached
to a finger it just sends kind of random
noise on analog so it looks like we're
kind of starting to normalize a little
bit on device here I'm trying to make
sure that I've got it
yeah okay I want to highlight two things
that just happened
so first the angular app that's on stage
now is reading from fire store in real
time any of the sensors that are getting
pushed once a second up into the cloud
are being yeah I'm still going are being
shown here so you see you know my BPM is
about 107 I'm excited and too Alysha
made a change to my device in fire store
on her front end and it was almost
instantly recognized in the angular app
and updated live so Rob I do like what
we've done here but it's a little it's
gonna be hard to tell side-by-side you
know who's actually the most nervous can
we get all five of us in a graph sure I
can give you a minute while he's doing
that I'm gonna talk about her second
friend app with what Alysha has been
working on can we switch to Alicia's
laptop so while we're doing this once
we're hooked up Mart
market in Callum you guys are getting
hooked up Rob when you're done with the
graph go ahead and you get hooked up to
hopefully now we've got Alicia's screen
is gonna come up soon
okay so well while we're getting her set
up here the second friend that we're
doing is gonna be Google Google sheets G
suite backed by Apps Script so I just do
we know about Apps Script a couple do
good that's why I want to do this talk
so we could highlight the fact that
we've got Apps Script going on so we see
on screen now is her screen and it's
showing the metadata configuration page
so this is where she changed my name
/ - that destroyer of worlds value so I
know a lot of you were thinking like
yeah and she changed a value it's
happening a real-time we just built it
it's going from one front dent through
the cloud and updating in a second front
end the next thing I want to show off is
the next tab is the ability to configure
our devices in some fashion and this is
where we we really see how this is gonna
go so right now you are devices we have
a value called the heartbeat threshold
so if my heartbeat goes above that
threshold the LED that's on this device
is gonna light up right now it's set to
999 because we knew that when the things
aren't connected they send really high
values and we didn't want it to
accidentally go off early so now let's
go ahead and set the threshold down to
120 which both I should be able to hit
and I shouldn't hit at the moment so
what I'm gonna try and do here is see if
I can get it to trigger and get this
light to go on hang in there
I am really out of shape
alright so I heart I love you I love the
music choice does alright so now we get
to the play of the game of how long does
it take Gabe's heart rate to go back
below 120 probably a while so how this
works from sheets we've got a single
cell that when she enters the the
threshold into it it rates all over all
of our devices and fires off to another
cloud function it's a second cloud
function that Martin wrote and all it
does is it calls the AI the IOT admin
SDK and sends that configuration message
back down to all of our advices to
update them yes I know I'm out of shape
so it does the the app script is calling
HTTP to call into that second cloud
function so it's not a trigger it's
actually using that first method that I
talked about with the cloud functions
the last piece that I wanted to show off
when I switch to this the airwheel is
this is the time slice data I was
talking about so she is fetching the
data from the last 60 seconds or so me
so that big the the the Jaggi spec
that's me running around the room cuz so
with sheets you get up to 2 million
cells of data so what she's is really
good at pulling in large amounts of data
so down the the graphing is gonna be
similar to the angular but I wanted to
highlight it's the time slice not the
real time that the angular is so that's
what we want to highlight for sheets is
that you're looking at historical data
not live down below now is we've got
some conditional formatting so anytime
my heart rate is above the set threshold
it's being conditionally formatted in
that red so it's a quick way to get just
a quick and dirty look at your data by
doing some analysis in semi real-time so
that you can see what's happening so now
I would like to go through the Apps
Script code if Alicia would be so kind
sure so I think some of you raised your
hands but for those of you that don't
know Apps Script is a scripting language
based on JavaScript with a bunch of
enhancements for G sweet to be able to
automate between different Google
products and services so the first line
of code I want to show you is just where
I query firestore so I'm using a library
that connects Apps Script to fire store
and I'm querying for a specific device I
had gapes device up there
most recent 60 measurements so then I'm
taking that return list of measurements
and I'm appending a new row to the
spreadsheet for each for each
measurement and kind of in between there
I wanted to know what time slice it
really represented because they are sent
about once a second but I'm pulling the
first and last measurement and just
notating that start and stop time and
then finally I'm adding some conditional
formatting down here creating a
conditional formatting roll so that any
BPM value over the current threshold is
made into a background color of red
awesome Thank You Alicia so now we've
seen how Apps Script does it pulling and
showing the data Rob talked to me how we
doing on grass all right so let's switch
back over to Rob and we will see look
hey it's our heart rates all on screen
so each of us has our own color and now
I want to know Alysha go ahead and get
hooked up to your device
that's so she's in yellow that's that
like squiggly way up high that's the
garbage data that I was talking about so
when she gets properly hooked it's
already dipping down so what color was i
I was blue I want to be the coolest I'm
not the coolest Wow let's are you still
alive I'm blue I get to be the coolest
cucumber on stage check that out we're
all pretty close though so um the
question has been answered I get to be
and I'm an out-of-shape I just ran
around the room what's wrong with you
people so Rob now that we've kind of
seen it let's go into your code and so
we've seen Apps Script do the data
pulling now I want to show you off the
angular app doing the data pulling so go
ahead or up okay switch over to my
editor so I'm using angular and
obviously I used the angular CLI to go
ahead and scaffold a project so it's
setup tooling and building and all that
stuff that's really hard about
JavaScript I started the first thing we
looked at was our devices screen and
that's just a couple of screens so I've
got a very simple device list component
a little bit of HTML with some angular
bindings
we're just iterating over our devices
and rendering some data one of the nice
things about angular is that we have a
really really good relationship with
firebase so we have a really nice built
in firebase angular library angularfire
store so it takes a one line of code to
talk to firestore extract that data and
then I get a real-time display of that
we go a little more in depth in Dora
you you can see we're doing the same
thing we're just using our built-in
angular fire service we are just
extracting data again you know getting
some routing parameters and just
streaming the last measurements off of
the device so that's kind of basic and a
templating that works pretty simply for
the pulse graph because that's a lot
more complicated we're using d3 which is
an awesome graphing library that's open
source again we're just talking to
firebase getting that device data coming
out I won't bore you all the math we're
going on in here but basic we're taking
the BPM and the timestamp and scaling
them so I fit in the screen and just
rendering a line across the screen so
there you go sweet thank you rob
so let's go back to slides yep all right
so to recap since the the keynote went a
little long so I'm trying to wrap us up
so we get us all back on schedule we
built an entire app on stage in front of
you in 35 minutes that we went to from
custom devices custom devices up and
through IOT core bridge into cloud cloud
pub/sub cloud functions to pull from
pub/sub into cloud fire store fire store
firing real-time updates to power our
angular app Google sheets powered by
Apps Script to pull to show us time
slice data configure our devices with an
LED that will not shut off for me and
and what else it and I configured
metadata in the in fire store as well
that is our end-to-end simple data
application all the way through Thank
You team for making all of that happen
thank you for coming
[Music]